قال الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب ان
ادارته ملتزمه بالتوصل الى اتفاق للسلام
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وانها
ستبدا مسارا تامل ان يؤدي الى ذلك اما
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس فقال اثناء
لقائه ترامب بواشنطن ان الوقت قد حان
لانهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والاعتراف
بدوله
فلسطين
السلام عليكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش
فيما
وراءه هل للاداره الامريكيه الجديده
مقاربه مختلفه عن سابقاتها بشان القضيه
الفلسطينيه والى اي حد يمكن للقاء ترامب
عباس ان يتجاوز الشكليات ويعيد تحريك
عمليه السلام المعطله بين الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
والاسرائيليين الرئيس الامريكي مهتم
ومتحمس ولديه رؤيه للحل السياسي هكذا قال
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس بعد لقائه
الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب في واشنطن
في المقابل قال ترامب ان ادارته ملتزمه
بالتوصل الى اتفاق للسلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وان لديها مسارا ستبدا
قريبا وتامل ان يفضي الى تحقيق السلام في
الشرق الاوسط فما هي المؤشرات على ان
للاداره الامريكيه الجديده فعلا رؤيه
سياسيه مختلفه عما تعاقب على البيت الابيض
من ادارات وهل باتت الاجواء مواتيه
اقليميا ودوليا لاحياء عمليه السلام تقرير
زياد
بركات في لقاءات ترامب تبدو الصور حاسمه
في دلالاتها هنا تحديدا في منتصف فبراير
شباط يلتقي الرجل وزوجته رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو وعقيلته يبدو
اللقاء حميميا وعائليا بامتياز وذاك امر
حاس في علاقات بعض الرؤساء الامريكيين
الذين تشكل العلاقه الشخصيه معيارا بالغ
الاهميه لهم في مقاربه بعض القضايا
انحيازا او فتورا الصوره هنا تنحاز
لنتنياهو على حساب محمود عباس الرجل
القادم من رام الله بملفات ثقيله يقول
اركان في اداره ترامب انه لا يتمتع بالصبر
الكافي للغرق في تفاصيلها لكنه يلتقيه
ويحرص اي ترامب على ان يبدو ودودا في
استقباله فل الرجلين مصلح في اللقاء حتى
لو كان لالتقاط الصور فحسب تحدث ترامب اقل
من عباس قال انه سيبذل كل ما هو ضروري
للتوسط من اجل تحقيق السلام لكنه لم يتحدث
بشكل واضح ومباشر حول حل الدولتين واكتفى
بخلاصه قد تبدو تبسيطيه تفيد بان الاتفاق
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين ربما لا
يكون صعبا كما اعتقد الناس على مدى سنوات
يرجع البعض ذلك ومنهم اتش ار ماكماستر
مستشار ترامب الى ما يسميه نهج ترامب
الابتكاري غير القائم على النقاش بل على
تحدي السياسات الفاشله بعقليه رجل الاعمال
الذي يسعى لتحقيق النتائج ربما راهن عباس
على هذه الصفه التي تنعت بالنرجسيه لدى
ترامب وهو يخاطبه ويشيد بحكمته وشجاعته
وبقدرته التفاوضيه العظيمه وكلها صفات لم
تجرب بعد لدى رئيس اكمل بالكاد المئه يوم
الاولى من ولايته لكن لعباس مارب اخرى
ربما ثمه ازمه تتدحرج في رام الله وبقيه
اراضي السلطه الفلسطينيه الاسرى يضربون عن
الطعام ونجم مروان البرغوثي يصعد ويهدد
وفي غزه مسيرات تندد بسياسات الرجل التي
يصفونها بالعقاب والهادفه الى ما يقولون
انه تركيع لغزه بهدف تمرير صفقه سلام
محتمله ومجحف وهناك ايضا محور عربي يتصلب
ويقف خلف محمد دحلان في مواجهه عباس
اللقاء مع ترامب يمنح الرجل دفعه معنويه
قويه فما زال هو الخيار الرسمي للدول
الكبرى وتلك رساله لبلدان في المنطقه تلعب
في الوقت الضائع عندما تتداول اسماء بديله
عنه في راي مناصره قد يفسر ذلك احجام عباس
عن مطالبه ترامب علنا بالضغط على نتنياهو
لوقف الاستيطان فهو يعرف ان اوباما لم
يستطيع اجبار رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على
وقف الاستيطان واذا كان هذا شان اوباما
الذي مارس ضغوطا على تلبيب من اجل ذلك
وفشل فماذا يكون الوضع وقد اصبح ترامب هو
الرئيس وهو اقرب الى الروايه الاسرائيليه
ان لم يكن احد اشرس المقاتلين من اجلها
حتى قبل ان ينتخب نرحب بضيوفنا الثلاثه في
هذه الحلقه ديفيد بولوك كبير الباحثين في
معهد واشنطن لسياسات الشرق الادنى
والمسؤول السابق في الخارجيه الامريكيه من
رام الله الدكتور احمد عزم استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه بيرزيت ومن عمان الكاتبه
الصحفيه لميس اندوني نبدا بواشنطن والسيد
ديفيد
بولوك هل هناك ايه مؤشرات على ان ترامب في
تعامله مع المساله الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
يختلف عن الرؤساء
السابقين
نعم
اكيد يختلف انا اعتقد اولا بالانحياز الى
اسرائيل بالصراحه كامله
وبالانجلش خاص ولكن على الرغم من ذلك او
يمكن حتى بسبب ذلك بالضبط انا اعتقد ان هو
الرئيس الجديد دونالد ترامب قادر على
اقناع اسرائيل
ل عمليه السلام بشكل فعالي
ومدرج خطوه خطوه
وبدون الاعتبار الى الحل النهائي ولكن ب
انا اعتقد لصالح الحياه الفلسطينيه في
الاراضي المحتله مثلا تحديد الاستيطان لا
تجميد او ايقاف الاستيطان بشكل مطلق ولكن
تحديد الاستيطان ما داخل الجدار من ناحيه
والتحرك الاقتصادي الفلسطيني اكثر مما كان
في الماضي برخصه من اسرائيل يحتوي على
رخصه للعمال الفلسطينين
لشغل في اسرائيل مثلا وكذا وكذا ولذلك انا
اعتقد انه نحن الان لازم نتكلم لا عن
التسويه
النهائيه ولكن على الخطوات اجاء هذه
التسويه في المستقبل البعيد ولكن كل هذه
العناصر الدكتور احمد عزم هل يمكن ان تشكل
رؤيه لان الرئيس الفلسطيني وصف ترامب بانه
متحمس ويملك رؤيه سياسيه هل تصل هذه
المؤشرات التي اشار اليها السيد بولك الى
حد تبلورها في رؤيه
واضحه يعني انا لا اعتقد بانه هناك اي
تبلور لتصور واضح لدى ترامب للبدء بنوع من
لفرض او للتوصل لتسويه نهائيه الان يعني
انا اتفق جزئيا فقط مع ضيفك الاستاذ بولك
اي من حيث انه ما يسعى اليه الان الرئيس
ترامب هو بلوره رؤيه لعمليه سلام وليس
للسلام هو هو ما يسعى اليه الان ما يتضح
الان من تصريحاته ومن تحركاته بانه هو
يريد ان يرى كيف يمكن ان يطلق عمليه سلام
الفرق بينها وبين ما كان يطرح سابقا بانه
يريد ان يكرر شيء شبيه بما حصل في قمه
كامب ديفيد سنه 2000 من الحديث عن محاوله
اطلاق تصور لا اطلاق عمليه تنهي المفاوضات
في فتره سريعه وجزء من ذلك ايضا محاوله
ادخال العنصر الاقليمي العنصر العربي الى
هذه الرؤيه ربما يعني هو عندما سيزور
المنطقه بعد حوالي 18 يوم 17 يوم سيبدا
بزياره الرياض ثم سياتي الى فلسطين
لمقابله الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين هنا
وثم سيذهب الى روما يعني انا باعتقادي هذه
الجوله تعبر اولا بناء يعني ذهابه الى
السعوديه اولا هي محاوله لبلوره او الاخذ
نوع من الضوء الاخضر في السعودي
لعمليه سلام ربما يكون فيها بعد
اقليمي ولكن انا باعتقادي بانه لن يجد
تماما ما يتوقع في السعوديه او حتى في
القدس وا او في فلس او في رام الله في
المقابل هذه المزج بين
الرياض القدس روما فيه نوع من انواع ربما
التفكير الحلم بانه سيكون رجل السلام الذي
يتحدث عن الاسلام والمسيحيه واليهوديه
بالذهاب الى هذه العواصم الثلاث ومقابله
البابا في روما يعني انا باعتقادي ترامب
الان في مرحله الحلم وفي مرحله محاوله ان
يظهر بالمظهر البطولي الذي يستطيع ان يحقق
انجازات تاريخيه لم تحقق سابقا وجزء من
هذا الموضوع محاوله اطلاق عمليه سلام
جديده ولكنه لا يوجد في كل ما قاله اي
تصور للحل الرئيس الفلسطيني كان حريص امس
واضح بان يكرر على مسامع ترامب المطالب او
الرؤيه الفلسطينيه للسلام فف نعم ولكن
ولكن ولكن ضيفنا سيد بولك بعد اذك سيد عزم
ضيفنا السييد بولوك اشار الى انحياز ترامب
لاسرائيل ربما هذه النقطه قد لا يكون هناك
رئيس امريكي اكثر انحياز لاسرائيل من اخر
يعني تقريبا يعني عنصر عنصر ثابت في
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه ولكن السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه سيده لميس اندوني
السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه وصفها السيد ماك مستر مستشار
الامن القومي ماك ماستر قال قال بانه نهج
ترامب نهج ابتكاري وفي الموضوع الفلسطيني
هو لديه نهج جديد وغير تقليدي هل هل لمست
شيئا من
هذا لا لم المس شيئا من هذا يعني هو يتكلم
تكتيكيا وليس
استراتيجيا السياسه الامريكيه استراتيجيا
لم ولن تتغير لكن الفرق هو ان امريكا الان
بحاجه الى تفاهم اقليمي امني يضم السعوديه
ويضم اسرائيل ويضم كل الدول العربيه ولذا
هو حريص ترامب او اداره ترامب حريصه بان
يكون هناك ليس تسويه اقليميه بقدر ما
تفاهم او
تحالف اقليمي امني لكن هذا التحالف لا لا
لا لا يستطيعون اظهاره الى العلن وشرعنته
دون ان يخلق وهم بان هناك افق
ل لحل القضيه الفلسطينيه
وكل كل ما يحدث في الدوائر المقربه من
صناعه القرب بواشنطن ومنها
المركز واشنطن دراسات الشرق الادنى
تحديد ابقاء
الوهم ابقاء وهم بحل دولتين حيا حتى لا
يثور الفلسطينيون
وحتى يعطوا هامش مناوره للدول العربيه
للحكومات العربيه بان تدخل بهذا الحلف
الاقليمي اما بما تحدث عن السيد بولك وهو
هذا هو خط المؤيدين لاسرائيل في واشنطن
فهو ما يتحدث
عن تجميد محدود للمستوطنات هو داخل الجدار
العنصري الانعزالي والفصل العنصري
هو يعني على الارض خلق خارطه خلق واقع على
الارض تمهيدا لضم كل المستوطنات كتل
الاستيطانيه الكبيره في القدس وفي الضفه
الغربيه الى اسرائيل وكل وكل ذلك وكل ما
ععد ذلك هو مجرد وهم ويجب ان نذكر هنا ان
الطلب الرئيسي الامريكي هو وقف التحريض
ووقف التحريض يعني تجريد الفلسطينيين من
كل ادوات المقاومه السلميه والدبلوماسيه
والانقضاض على الاسرى او
تقويض نضال الاسرى خاصه الحراك الرئيسي
نعم ولكن ولكن ال اللافت سيده اللافت سيده
اندوني ان ربما هذا التقييم العربي
المتحفظ حول هذه النتائج هناك ايضا تقييم
اسرائيلي سيد بولك يعني الاسرائيليون
تابعوا باهتمام كبير هذه القمه ترامب عباس
الحقيقه لفت انتباهي اليوم مقال في في
هارتس بقلم برك ربيد يقول تحت عنوان عنوان
معبر يقول كلما تغيرت الامور كلما بقيت
على حالها كلما تغيرت الامور كلما بقيت
على حالها يقول عن ترامب هو لم يخترع شيئا
ولم يغير قواعد اللعبه
ويحاول الدفع بعمليه السلام بالاسلوب نفسه
وبالوسائل نفسها وحماسه الذين سبقوه
وبالتالي يبدو ان هناك تواصل لما سبق هل
هذا
دقيق بشكل اعم هذه المره بصراحه كامله
وبكل الاحترام انا اتفق مع الصحفي
الاسرائيلي
بش
عاده انا شخصيا انا اقيم ان صحيفه ارتس
تنعكس الرؤيه اليسريه يعني الاقليه
القليله الصغيره داخل اسرائيل ولكن في
هذه هذا التقييم انا اعتقد صحيح انه ليس
هناك التغيير جوهري في الموقف الامريكي
وال يمين الاسرائيلي لا يخاف لا من هذه
الالتقاء بين دونالد ترامب
والرئيس السيد محمود عباس ولا من
التصريحات الامريكيه الاخرى المعنى انه
الاسرائيليين انا اعتقد مطمئنين من
السياسه الامريكيه ومن هذه العمليات
السلام الجديده المدرجه
البطيئ
الخفيفه ولكن انا بكل الاحترام انا اخالف
مع
السيده التي قالت انه
سيدوني الاستيطان الاستيطان غير محدود
وهذا يشير
على رغبه امريكا او رغبه اسرائيل للدمج او
لاحتلال مستمر على الضفه الغربيه بشكل
كامل لا انا اعتقد بالعكس هذا انا اعتقد
يثبت انه مبدا مبادله الاراضي هذا المبدا
الذي اتفق الفلسطينين انفسهم عليه هذا
المبدا قائم مبادله الاراضي المعنى انه
المستوطنات القريبه من حدود
67 هي وفقط هي التي سوف تدمج الى اراضي
اسرائيل في حاله التسويه السلميه النهائيه
في حاله حل الدولتين نم في المستقبل نعم و
سئر الضفه الغربيه سوف تكون خاليه من
الاحتلال في المستقبل بعد ال بعد انتهاء
المفاوضات في المستقبل
البعيد وبنسبه للتحريض التحريض بمعنى
التحريض العنفي التحريض الى عمليات
الاستشهاد والارهاب والقتل هذا هو الذي
يحرمه ال ال
الحكومه الامريكيه تحرمه
ولكن المظاهرات
السلميه التصريحات المفاوضات الصمود على
الارض فلسطين وكل هذا بشكل سلمي هذا حلال
يعني هذا مفهوم هذا مقبول ن ولكن سيد بولك
يعني واضح واضح من كلامك سيد بولك وكلام
سيده اندوني
وسيد عزم بان لا توجد مؤشرات مشج
تماما بناء على ما جرى في هذا اللقاء ومع
ذلك ومع ذلك سنت سءل بعد الفاصل الى اي حد
يمكن لهذا اللقاء ان يتجاوز الشكليات
ويعيد بشكل او باخر تحريك عمليه السلام
المعطله منذ 2014
[موسيقى]
لنعود
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ال نتائج المرجوه
من لقاء الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب
بالرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس دكتور احمد
عزم الرئيس الفلسطيني الرئيس ترامب عفوا
خاطب الرئيس الفلسطيني قائلا انه يرى فرصه
جيده هذا كلامه بالضبط يرى فرصه جيده
واعتقد انك يعني الرئيس عباس تشعر بنفس
الطريقه هل تعتقد فعلا انه توجد الان رغم
ما ذكرتموه قبل قليل توجد فرص
جديده لاحياء المفاوضات وجهود
التسويه يعني بدايه قبل ان اجيب عن السؤال
اريد ان اخاطب السيد بولك
بشيء بعباره قصيره عن موضوع المستوطنات
يعني انا باعتقادي انه احد الاكاذيب
الكبرى انما يوجد في الضفه الغربيه كتل
استيطان كبرى لا يوجد شيء يسمى كتل
استيطان كبرى وفقط الضفه الغربيه الان
اشبه بقطعه جبن سويس مليئه بالثقوب فلينظر
الى الخارطه الان على اي موقع على
الانترنت المستوطنات الان هي اشبه بالبثور
على وجه تملاه في كل مكان لا يوجد ما يس
هناك افاعي استيطان والاسرائيليون يقولون
انهم لن ينسحبوا من الاغوار فبالتالي ليس
صحيحا ان هناك مستوطنات ستبقى كما يروج
الاسرائيليون ستبقى معهم في اطار تبادل
المستوطنات في كل مكان يعني انا المكان
اللي اجلس فيه على بعد كيلومترات من جميع
الاتجاهات في مستوطنات ارجع لموضوع الفرصه
يعني نحن يجب ان نفرق بين موضوعين مهمين
موضوع فرصه لمفاوضات وفرصه لعمليه سلام
المفاوضات كانت مستمره منذ حوالي الان
نقترب على 30 عام من المفاوضات 26 27 سنه
من المفاوضات ف اذا كان الحديث عن اطلاق
مفاوضات نعم ربما الرئيس الفلسطيني امس
وضح الموقف الفلسطيني ولكنه لم يتطرق
لفكره الذهاب الى الامم المتحده او
الاجراءات التي كانت الا التي كانت مرفوضه
او ما يسمى تدويل الصراع فالحل الان
انتظار ما الذي سيطرحه ترامب لاعاده عمليه
السلام بالطريقه التقليديه التي ملها
الفلسطينيون والتي قال الرئيس الفلسطيني
وفريقه المفاوض قبل اربع اعوام تقريبا
بانها غير مجديه فالان هناك فرصه لانه
هناك رغبه في ذلك ولكن
ال المعيار الحقيقي لقياس التقدم واذا كان
هناك سيكون مفاوضات وستستمر او لا تستمر
هل يوجد تصور للتوصل لحل نهائي اذا كنا
نتحدث عن حل اقتصادي وعن موضوع تحسين
اوضاع اقتصاديه وتج جزئي للاستيطان فانا
باعتقادي بان الاراضي الفلسطينيه متجهه
للانفجار نحن شهدنا في 2015 هبه الان
لدينا تفاعل غير مصبوغ مع موضوع الاسرى
ولا اعتقد ان الوضع يحتمل ابدا على في
الميدان وعلى الارض مثل هذه الامور الشعب
الفلسطيني مل على الارض هناك جيل جديد ليس
جيل اوسلو الذي لا يرتبط بكل منظومه اوسلو
من رواتب واجهزه ومؤسسات وهو يريد ان يريد
تغيير مل الحياه الحاليه اذا كان
الامريكان واي طرف اقليمي يفكر بانه يمكن
اعاده عاده انتاج الماضي من مفاوضات عبثيه
جزئيه تدريجيه فانا باعتقادي ان هذا نوع
من عدم الفهم ابدا لما يجري على الارض نعم
هناك ايضا فكره سيده لميس اندوني فكره
طريفه الحقيقه ايضا وارده في مقال هارتس
اليوم يقول المقال بان سواء نتنياهو او
عباس يدركان قوه الردع التي لدى ترامب
شخصيته توحي بانه مخيف بين قوسين يمكن ان
يقدم على اشياء غير متوقعه وان هذه القوه
قوه الردع هذه قد تشكل فرصه
لاطلاق شيء جديد في في مسار
التسويه هل تراها
كذلك
ايه الفكره اولا انه ممكن انه
تتم اطلاق التسويه وخاصه اذا تدخلت دول
عربيه وهذا والهدف هو خلق حاله ضغط عربيه
على الجانب الفلسطينيه الفلسطيني حتى يدخل
في العمليه اذا كان اسمها عمليه جديده
للسلام لكن هذا يعني مفصول عن الواقع لانه
بالنهايه هناك وضع على الارض انتفاضه
الاسرى التفاعل معها حركه المقاطعه
ايه المشكله الرئيسيه ليست بما يحدث في
واشنطن ما يحدث في واشنطن هي مصلحه
امريكيه
وتطويع الوضع الفلسطيني لمصلحه اسرائيل
والاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في المنطقه او
الاهداف الامريكيه في
المنطقه الافق الوحيد للشعب الفلسطيني هو
اول شيء استمرار بكل اساليب المقاومه ان
كانت
خاصه من خلال المقاطعه من خلال ذهاب الى
المؤسسات دوليه من خلال دعم الاسرى واهم
شيء ان لا يرضخ الرئيس الفلسطيني للمطالب
الامريكيه بان يقطع معاشات الاسرى وراتب
الاسرى والشهداء يعني هذا محاوله ليس فقط
لتقويه الفكر المقاومه الفلسطيني هذا فرض
الاستسلام الفلسطيني و وتجريم المقاومه
ثانيا
ان التركيز الرئيسي يجب ان يكون على بناء
مشروع وطني فلسطيني ما فائده اذا بدات
عمليه السلام بالشروط السابقه فهي ليست
فقط فاشله فهي خطيره على الشعب الفلسطيني
ف الفشل شيء والخطر شيء
اخر اسس انيكون هناك الفت بعد اذنك انه
الرئيس الامريكي استعمل كلمه فرصه وهناك
شخص اخر استعمل كلمه فرصه اسال عنها السيد
بولوك من استعمل كلمه فرصه ايضا هو خالد
مشعل في مقابلته مع سي ان ان قال قال ان
دون قال ان دونالد ترامب عليه التقاط
الفرصه لاعطاء دفع جديد لعمليه السلام في
الشرق الاوسط والتوصل الى حل منصف ووصف
خالد مشعل ترامب بانه يملك جراه
التغيير ولديه جراه تفوق الادارات
الامريكيه السابقه من قال هذا الكلام هو
خالد مشعل الى اي مدى تعتقد سيد بولك ان
الكل
يدفع نحو هذا التوجه لدى ترامب ه هل يمكن
ان يحصل
ذلك انا شخصيا انا اقيم انه هذا الصحيح
دونالد ترامب هو كما قالوا الك
هو شخص غير عادي هو غير تقليدي هو
نادر بمعنى انا اعتقد ايجابي بالنسبه
للسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه الجديده غير
التقليديه وهناك فرص متنوعه من ناحيه او
بالنسبه للقضيه الفلسطينيه او القضايا
الاخرى في المنطقه وفي العالم ولكن في نفس
الوقت بالنسبه لحماس بشكل خاص انا اخام
وانا اعتقد انه الاداره الامريكيه تتفق
100% في هذا التقييم انه حماس لم يتغير
ابدا وليس هناك اي فرصه
لاحتواء حماس في عمليه السلام او في اي
مفاوضات او في اي سياسه امريكيه
حماس لاي زال في قائمه المجموعات
الارهابيه الرسميه الامريكيه وهذا لن
يتغير انا اعتقد في المستقبل شكرا جزيلا
لك سيد ديفيد بولوك من واشنطن شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من رام الله الدكتور احمد عزم
وشكرا لضيفنا من عمان لميس
اندوني في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ه